d'abord un phénomène money zednik et
sociale c'est à dire que c'est un
phénomène qui nous définissons comme tel
à travers une société qui a sa
spécificité culture nanar n'existerait
pas son contexte du temps de l'espace
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas un
phénomène que l'on peut pointer du doigt
pour vous nommez tel qu'il est comme ça
noir sur blanc mais il faut toujours le
de l'imaginer ou le concevoir dans un
contexte est donc cette histoire un
phénomène qui dépendent de son espace
temps et des spécificités culturelles du
groupe social qui le crée après on peut
se poser la question un peu qui me
paraît intéressante autour de la notion
du besoin et se dire est ce que l'art
est vraiment un besoin c'est à dire que
là on sait que c'est un phénomène qui
n'existerait qu'à travers un groupe
social et à travers et spécificités mais
après on peut se poser la question
maintenant est ce que l'art et house
mais pour pouvoir répondre il faut
essayer d'imaginer un peu que l'être
humain a des idées propres besoins et
que ce nom la théorie de la pyramide
devriez ou une partie devrait tout de
même la reconnaître qu'il a permis deux
matchs no qui parle des besoins humains
on peut imaginer que la base de cette
pyramide est plus large et que l'humain
a besoin de choses primordiales pour
jouer sa survie d'abord et que plus on
monte la pyramide us n'est besoin de
vienne pointures et deviennent devient
un peu d'ordre
je ne serai pas dire secondaire mais
plutôt sophistiqué et dont ce sont
ceux-là il ya peut-être une vision qui
pourrait être caricatural presque à dire
qu'après c'est à dire que finalement
c'est un mix mais en effet je dirais que
la pyramide est de même de match no 2
qui vient parce qu'on en parle
d'accomplissement et on a compté chic et
toc
c'est l'accomplissement probablement
encore une fois l'une des qualités qui
redéfinissent la différence entre l'être
humain et animal parce que c'est c'est
un accomplissement qui relève d'une
reconnaissance
psychologique et matérielle à la fois et
je crois donc coeur ou deux places en un
petit peu dans cette dimension de
l'accomplissement on lui rend hommage et
on comprend que voilà il est un peu
l'équivalent d'une accomplissement
humains et pour tenter aussi de rendre
ça plus simples et plus faciles on
pourrait dire que qu'un dessin conçoit
n'a pas une valeur à changer le regard
de l'humain sur l'humanité n'est qu'un
monument comme la pyramide le doré et
l'aurait cet impact de changer de regard
sur l'architecturé sur la notion de la
divinité et on ne peut pas imaginer que
ce qui ramène aurait pu être dessinées
sont pensés architectes et son procédé
si nana et c'est ainsi que le cercle se
bouclent un peu en disant que l'art est
un équipe intégrée dans différentes
dimensions des pratiques scientifiques
et humaines et que voilà il ya un peu
cette relation d'interaction entre l'art
comme champ a spécifié cas et les autres
champs après je pense que les deux
autres points que je voulais aborder
rapidement aussi parce que je crois que
mon intervention ne se sera pas très
longue parce que vous les buts en un peu
plus tôt que parler de mon parcours et
parler de choses personnelles j'ai boudé
plus tout peut-être me concentrer sur
certaines notions qui font confusion par
rapport à beaucoup de monde qui n'arrive
pas n'arrive pas à juger en aient fait
leur temps premièrement on a parlé un
peu de la définition que l'on peut dire
jusqu'à maintenant à usage symbolique
parce qu'on parle qu'est ce que
représente l'armée l'interaction avec d
autres secteurs et sa propre définition
qui les imitent
et là on j'aimerais plutôt à parler d'un
sujet qui la valeur de l'art c'est à
dire que cette valeur qui peut être
divisée en deux branches
essentiel et dans la première et à
valeur à l'usaf symbolique convient
d'évoquer maintenant c'est que qu'est-ce
que ce qu'est ce que l'art signifie
symboliquement et encore une fois
j'étais il ya deux trois jours avec un
jeune ami médecin qui nous pose une
question et qui me dit saison lequel
rihanna j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi
une oeuvre d'art est ce qu'est ce qui
fait qu'une renault a de la valeur et je
me suis contenté de lui donner mon
exemple la didactique que j'utilise
souvent avec légende pour expliquer un
peu pourquoi une oeuvre d'art turner on
y met en lui demandant d'imaginer qu'il
a entre les mains un dessin d'enfant et
que ce dessin d'enfant autres ses
mannequins de vin de valeur que qu'être
un dessin d'enfant
maintenant je lui demandé d'imaginer que
c'est son premier dessin qui n'aurait
fait que son existence c'est quelqu'un
de sa famille sa grand'mère son grand
père qui l'a gardée soigneusement et
kuduro fort à nouveau ce petit bout de
papier qui devient tout d'un coup la
première expérience que vous avez fait
maintenant on peut surenchérir une
deuxième fois a ajouté une couche et
dire imaginons que c'est pas son premier
dessin mais c'est le premier dessin que
son père a fait et qu'il a perdu son
père et que quelqu'un encore une fois le
regardé soigneusement que lui sort ce
bout de papier
maintenant est-ce qu'il a la même
estimation en termes d' échanges
matériels que la première estimation qui
l'avait quand il était un dessin
d'enfant normal maintenant il ne les
changera pas pour beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'il devient
quelque chose de symbolique pour lui et
c'est justement cette dimension
symbolique de conviction qui fait que
l'art devient quelque chose de neuf en
europe puisque en effet quand on arrive
à faire accroire et à faire croire aux
autres que quelque chose d'esthétique a
aussi une valeur échangeables monétaire
ou matérielle c'est parce que c'est par
conviction et son à conviction les pieds
d'argent serait aussi des bouts de
papiers que l'on peut déchirer ou brûlés
et encore une fois donc cette valeur un
visage matériel n'a d'existence qu'à
travers
soit disant qu'à travers un usage
symbolique d'abord c'est à dire que l'on
peut parler d'armes sous forme valeur
matérielle que si on parle d'amour de
valeur de valeur symbolique
après un point que qui me serait
intéressant d'évoquer aussi c'est de
rapprochement entre la le public général
c'est que je crois que il ya une forme
de barrière entre le public et les
pratiques artistiques et des musées et
des galeries etc
faire croire à surenchérir sur une
notion qui essaient de la mystification
et que c'est un univers compliqué c'est
un univers complexe est un univers qui
est souvent uniquement uniquement aux
initiés il qu'ils sont intégrés et je
crois que lorsqu'on lorsqu'on aime un
petit peu prendre une distance
intellectuelle par rapport à tous ou
presque philosophique du crois que je
crois que l'art devient aussi un champ
que l'on peut débattre que donc auquel
on peut avoir accès qu on peut même
enrichir en terme de public et
j'aimerais j'aimerais quand même croire
que ces idées par exemple de nature
pédagogique que j'ai développée
rapidement comme je dis parce que je ne
crois pas que mon intervention a duré
très longtemps qu'ils ont permis un peu
peut-être moins jeunes de ré imaginer un
petit peu les notions de la valeur de où
les notions de la définition de la